hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his short work on controlling anger
Plutarch is going to place into the
mouth of the main interlocutor from
dandas this idea that we need to train
ourselves away from anger and he's
rather realistic about this he doesn't
expect that we're going to train
ourselves to the point that we never
feel anger at all or give in to it a
little but it's important to think of
this as an ongoing process that involves
changing not just our ideas and Outlook
and behavior but also our habits our way
of being in the world and pretty late in
the the discussion he says that it's
true that all of the passions all of the
emotions need a process of habituation
an Ethics most right which fa is is the
Greek term for habit so ethics most this
process of cultivating or you could say
taking away habits that we have and he
says it tames as it were and subdues by
training and that's another key term
escasis the word that we get aesthetic
from escasis means training the kind of
thing that you would do by going to the
gym or by deliberately engaging in
philosophical practices so anger like
all of the other emotions is going to
require this and for Plutarch why is
this the case well he is a middle
platonist which means that he accepts
the platonic division of the Soul into
rational and irrational parts and the
irrational parts are multiple and so he
says that this trains the irrational the
a logon and the obstinate or the more
literally unwilling to listen the uh
Deuce pathace part of the Soul so this
is very important we all have this part
of our personality or soul and it's by
the time we start looking at it uh it's
already in some bad shape from the
perspective of of our emotions so we
need to attend to that and start working
at us or fixing it and this is going to
take time
now earlier on in the work actually at
the very beginning of his discussion
when when his friend has complimented
him and saying wow you used to be such
an angry person how did you change how
did you become less angry he says well
you know I started doing things
different in my condition and he he
starts talking about reason and anger
logos the part of us that does the
thinking right which again from the
platonic perspective should be the part
in charge oftentimes isn't the
irrational and obstinate part will often
be in charge and reason is understood
here in a number of different
interesting ways there's some metaphors
going on here and fundanas is going to
say
I don't think reasons should be used in
one's cure as we use hell bore and be
washed out of the body together with the
disease any he'll go on and say it's not
like a drug right you don't you don't
take it the reason meaning the
reasonable precepts or things like that
and then you're good and you go back to
living your irrational life no reason
needs to be something more like he says
good food that we take in and digest and
make part of ourselves which implies
that we could be more or less rational
or reasonable that we can make reason
build within ourselves and we can also
listen to the reasonable advice precepts
of other people as well so he says it
has to remain in the soul and keep watch
and Ward over the judgments the crisis
and this is an important term that we're
going to see coming up a little bit
later our judgments are often what get
us into trouble right so reason has to
pay attention to them and the more our
reason is developed the better we're
going to be at that so he says that
the power of Reason can you know be in
great Vigor in those who become
accustomed to it but when other people
give us advice even if it is reasonable
if they're applied to the passions when
they're at their height and swollen they
can't do much at all unless we've
actually sort of prepared ourselves
within right and he says that you know
anger can be particularly difficult
because the other passions will in fact
listen to reason when it comes from
without somebody else to the rescue but
temper doesn't right because uh unless
we've actually prepared the ground when
we're being irrationally angry and
somebody points that out to us or they
give us some advice we get angry at them
as well we don't want to hear it right
this is a common feature of anger so
what can we do well anger the danger
here is that it's going to to push
reason completely out it's actually this
great ex oikias right kicking somebody
out of the house saying get the hell out
of here right this is my place so a
anger will do that to us and he says it
shuts out this completely and locks it
out just like those who burn themselves
up in their own homes it makes
everything within full of confusion and
smoking noise so that the soul can
either hear nor see anything that might
help it and then he's got another very
interesting uh comparison here he says
that a ship that's in trouble right a
ship that is deserted by her crew in the
midst of a storm far out at Sea it could
take on a pilot from the outside
somebody who could steer the ship but
only if it's ready to do that sort of
thing he says a ship will will take on a
pilot more easily than a man being
tossed on the Billows of passion and
anger thumo Kai orge I have two words
that are used for anger by uh Plutarch
here uh the person who's being tossed on
these will hardly admit the reasoning of
another unless
he has his own powers of reason
prepared to receive it so how do we in
fact prepare our capacity our power our
faculty of reason to be able to take on
advice coming from the outside well we
have to fortify it ahead of time so he
says just like those who are expecting a
Siege right to be under attack for a
long time collect up and store all
that's useful to them
so it's most important we acquire in
advance the
reinforcements boy themata
um you know literally the running to the
aid things or the running to the aid
people we need to have
you could you could say our heads
stocked up with the things that are
going to help us against anger ahead of
time and he says that philosophy
provides these against anger and
we need to convey them into the soul and
the knowledge that when the occasion for
using them comes it is not going to be
possible to introduce them easily we
need them there already so we need to do
our anger management before we actually
start getting angry so that when we are
in fact feeling anger we've already got
some some plans some reinforcements some
techniques in place that will allow us
to to do that
now there's a number of ways he talks
about doing this in the work we're going
to come to a few of them here but before
that he also talks about this uh Danger
when angry says persists and its
outbursts are frequent then there is
created in the soul a bad State a uh he
calls it poneron something something
wicked something bad within the soul
that we call irascability in Greek
orgilotes right so Oregon is the word
for anger itself the feeling that we
feel organotes is this disposition to
feel anger excessively too quickly at
the wrong targets for the wrong reason
it's a anger ability you could say right
a liability to become angry when we say
that somebody has anger problems that is
a contemporary word for this
irascability that Plutarch is concerned
about and he says that you know once
you've got this this results in sudden
outbursts of rage and being you know
difficult being bitter P Korean right
and being peevish duskolian right these
these things result and when The Temper
becomes he says ulcerated easily
offended liable to find fault for even
trivial offenses like a weak piece of
iron which is always getting
scratch so if we get angry over and over
and over again and again we often
realize this after this has actually
happened to us we wind up in this state
which is going to be
you know we're more vulnerable to to
becoming angry so what can we do then
well
once again we see this term judgment
crisis right we need judgment which can
oppose these fits of anger so judgment
opposes it by saying the right thing to
do in this case is I'm getting angry
okay I need to do something about this
you know I need to like not I can be
angry but not act on the anger don't say
anything being silent is actually one of
the techniques that gets discussed and
he says that this will change our
condition not just in the present
but for the future we're modifying our
habits we're training ourselves to
approach things differently and at first
it seems like it's not going to work at
all and then he says something really
quite interesting here he says in my own
case at any rate when I had opposed
anger two or three times it came about
that I experienced what the thebans do
when they had for the first time
repulsed the Spartans who had the
reputation of being Invincible were
never
thereafter defeated by them in battle
what's he talking about there well so
the Spartans were the badasses of
ancient Greece for a very very long time
if the Spartans came on the field you'd
be like ah
where you can fight but we're gonna lose
you know because it's look it's the
Spartans right there right so in land
Warfare at least that was the case not
so great in Naval Warfare and who beat
them well the sacred band of Thebes
Thebes is a city far north of Athens and
they became a regional power and they
fought the Spartans and they kicked the
Spartans asses so the ass kickers got
their asses kicked and then once that
happens everyone else is like
oh wait a second the Spartans they're
not as tough as we think we we can beat
them right and the thebans were like we
already did beat them we can beat them
again well it's that way with anger yeah
it seems Invincible until we start
changing our habits until we start
engaging in some training stocking
ourselves up with the resources of
philosophy and then we discover oh no I
actually can beat anger and that's
that's what Plutarch has his speaker
Fontana saying that's what happened to
me he said not only did I see that anger
ceases when cold water is sprinkled on
it as Aristotle says but there's other
ways to do it as well a poultice so
poultice is like you know a bandage or
something like that to cure you of fear
we can use other Passions
fear can drive out anger we can be like
hey I I'm worried about what I'm gonna
do when I'm angry I don't want to offend
these people I don't want to ruin this
business deal I don't want to destroy my
relationship with my significant other
or my parents or my kids or my friends
therefore I better not allow the anger
to run away with me
or another very interesting emotion that
he's going to talk about a little bit
later
in terms of like laughing and stuff like
that Joy Harris or Hara here and
Joy being joyful can actually make us
lose that feeling of anger right so
that's that's quite good as well and he
says I came to the opinion this passion
is not all together
incurable at least for those who wish to
cure it and then he goes into one last
really important point he says anger
does not always have great and powerful
Beginnings if we are irascible types if
we're not in control of our anger even a
joke a playful word a burst of laughter
and not on the part of somebody Rouse
people to anger right and he gives you a
few examples and then he says so when
it's at the start when it's a small
thing it's sort of like kindling in a
campfire right he uses the example of
kindling a flame in rabbit's fur which I
guess maybe was something that they did
in ancient times or candle wicks or
rubbish if you stop the flame when it's
first forming it's not going to take
hold and then start spreading and all of
that so what you have to do is
extinguish the the flame of temper or
anger early on and if you can do that
well then you're not going to have to
struggle quite as much so what would
tell you to do that again
reason the irrational Part of Yourself
is not going to tell you to do that we
have to cultivate our faculty of reason
and do so in very clear and determinate
ways that will then allow us to keep our
anger under control and train ourselves
away from suffering from it